- Hey guys, Justine.
- And I'm Jenna.
- And we have another podcast episode.
Can you believe it that
we're at four episodes now.
- That's some serious commitment
that we are for filling.
- I mean we got four
episodes in three weeks,
that's like whoa.
- I don't think I've even
posted that many YouTube videos.
- I don't think so either,
'casue these have actually
taken way more time
than I thought they were gonna take.
- It's true.
- I was like this will just be a simple,
fun little, what was that?
- [Camera Operator] My airpod
- I thought gum fell out of your mouth
- So I'm gonna give you guys a couple
little highlights here
from this pod that is out.
I'm gonna put a link in the description
where you guys can check it out.
You guys can subscribe.
I'm so new to podcasts,
I don't listen to that many podcasts.
I mostly listen to murder podcasts.
(Jenna gasps)
- Dun dun dun.
- So, that, they can't hear that.
This set up is still kind of temporary.
We're borrowing some equipment right now
just testing out different some things
to see what will work.
I'm having so much fun.
- That's good that's what
life is sometimes about.
- This is a lot of work too,
it's fun but it's also work.
Like people don't realize how much time
and effort goes into making like anything.
We set up for three hours today.
- And Tyler did most of the work.
- I did a podcast before
this for somebody else
and then I came here
and did another podcast.
I am excited about the future of,
anyway I don't know, I'm not
even sure what I'm saying,
I need to go take a nap,
but, let's give some highlights
from today's podcast episode.
- Roll that clip.
Hey I'm Justine.
- And I'm Jenna.
- And you're listening to,
- Same Brain Podcast.
- Roll that intro.
(bouncy music)
- Wasn't that amazing, didn't
you love that little song?
- Oh my gosh, could you believe
it, that was incredible.
- That was great
- Very professional
- Tyler picked that out.
- This is our fourth podcast,
- Fourth?
- I believe so.
- We did two this week so we basically
doubled our podcast episodes this week.
- That is extremely impressive,
I just feel like there's so
much happening all the time.
We are here to cover all of it.
- One a week.
- Some of it.
- You know whatever, we've got
some fun little things here
that you guys requested on
twitter that we talk about.
- There's buttons that we can push.
- Yeah but don't push, no push.
- What if I push one?
- Just push one.
But don't push the one that
I don't want you to push
'casue it's so loud in my head.
- Oh all right then I'll push another one.
(magic noise)
- Oh
- Welcome to Same Brain.
- Wow, what's this one do?
(crickets chirp)
Oh that's the crickets.
- That's the crickets.
Oh my gosh we have five stars.
- How many reviews do we have?
- 186 reviews.
- Wait really? How?
- "Oh my gosh you guys
are so good at podcasting.
You keep me entertained
and your positive attitude is amazing,
keep up the good work. #SameBrain"
- Oh my goodness
- Another one, "Wow," I
forgot to read the last title.
"This is awesome."
This title is "Wow. Oh
my God this is amazing,
I listened to one episode and
I was immediately intrigued,
this is awesome guys keep it up,
I will be back every
Saturday to listen to this"
Oh no I hit the wrong one,
there's a clapping!
- No these are, yay.
(clapping)
- You know what Justine,
you know what's fun?
- What?
- Rumors about new tech.
Some rumors, Xbox related.
- Xbox, the code name is Lockhart,
which is kind of interesting.
So obviously you guys know
about the Xbox series X
that should be out this holiday.
Should be, I mean it will be out.
Who knows?
- You never know.
You really don't know.
It's expected, it has been
announced, holiday 2020
which is just around the corner.
But it's--
- Is it just around the river bend?
- No it's around the corner
- Okay, Xbox series One is expected to be
an absolute beast of a console.
Capable of playing video
games 4K 60 frames per second
so I could have a one
terabyte solid-state drive
and a ton of different specs here
which I feel like a lot of people
have already covered this stuff.
But me and Jenna are both huge Xbox fans.
- Oh yeah, I've been
playing so many video game
in quarantine, it's kinda crazy.
- Animal Crossing there is a summer update
and holey moley I'm incredibly excited.
But here's the thing,
I'm on the Southern Hemisphere
and this is like a summer update--
- You could start over?
- I will not.
I think I've hit 600 hours at this point.
- Wow
- We're not doing that.
So in the new update you'll be able
to swim and dive and find new,
so this is coming actually in July.
- July third.
It's right after July second
which I have a car appointment.
- Oh my gosh.
- It's my own plans of 2020.
Yeah so you can,
- Swimming, diving
- You can swim.
- And wetsuits.
For the first time ever in Animal Crossing
you'll be able to swim in the ocean
surrounding your island using a wetsuit.
The sea is yours to explore.
- I hit the microphone again.
- It's fine, oh my goodness
(failure sound effect)
So this article came up when
I was looking for Pokemon Go
'casue I feel like they
were supposed to relaunch
Pokemon Go but do you
remember how much fun we had?
- Yes, we were walking
like 20 miles a day.
- This article, it's Pokemon Go grandpa
plays with 64 phones on his bike.
Look at this picture Jenna!
- [Jenna] I'm looking at it first off,
how do you have that
many phone, how do you?
- This is the most, I am jealous
because this is how we
need to do phone reviews.
- [Jenna] It basically looks like
a peacock of phones.
- It does
- Like a peacock's tail.
That's insane, that's absolutely insane.
- I can't believe this is the day
that I first listened to BTS.
- Well so I've listened to them before.
- But I have not, why did nobody tell me
that they're incredible?
- I mean millions and millions
and hundreds of millions of people
have been telling people
that they're incredible.
- This is I think my problem,
is like I get super into stuff.
So I try to avoid things
that I know I'm gonna be
super into like World of Warcraft,
'casue I know that would
probably ruin my life.
But for some reason I just never,
everyone's like BTS, BTS, so good!
And the reason that I decided to finally
go and listen to BTS is because Samsung
did a collaboration with BTS
for one of their new phones, the S20 plus.
- It looks very, very good.
- This is the phone that I wanted.
- It's like a purplish, pinkish color.
- [Justine] It's so great,
it has little hearts on it.
- [Jenna] They also did
the buds as well I believe.
- Yes the Galaxy buds
- Oh my gosh.
- But can we talk about how good BTS is?
- Yeah, that's why millions
of people like them.
- I think it's even more than millions.
- Hundreds of millions.
- I am so upset that
it's taken me this long.
This is also something that
Tyler was talking about,
that he mentioned would be interesting
for us to chat about,
- Thanks Tyler.
- About Apple bringing touch screen back
to the next iPhone because of face masks.
Please, can we do that please?
- [Jenna] I miss it, personally.
- [Justine] I actually do,
when I started using the SE
I was like wow this is nice.
The fingerprint is faster
because I feel like
that slight swipe up is
actually, it takes more time
than if you just pick up your phone
and you would just pick it up
and touch where you need
to be and it just turns on.
- I kind of wish, what is the one
that has the one on the back?
- The Pixel's my favorite
- The Pixel yeah.
- It's a perfect location
for you pointer finger.
- What if you could do,
I don't really know.
- What don't you know?
- It's just something else,
I feel like there has to be something else
that someone hasn't thought of.
- Like Iris scanners?
- No 'casue that's still kind
of like face ID type of thing.
These glasses are really hurting my ears.
- I think the headphones
are also hurting my ears.
- Everything is hurting my head.
- I'm gonna take my headphones off.
- Okay yeah let's take a break
- Me too
I'm in a lot of pain.
- I mean I actually have to
actively take off my contacts,
take them out so I can
put these glasses on.
(bouncy music)